[Music]
water slides are awesome they kind of
like a rollercoaster but instead of you
being strapped into a vehicle you
physically are the vehicle and
completely at the mercy of the laws of
physics so what are the physics of water
slides
well the slide behind me is loan as the
leap of faith and you cannot see why and
the first thing to consider with a slide
like that its energy transfer whenever
something physically moves there's some
kind of energy exchange going on and in
this case is energy that takes your body
from the top to come shooting out the
bottom and an alarmingly fast and rather
Wiggy producing speed
[Music]
when I climb the stairs up there I'm
toning my body's chemical energy into
gravitational potential energy and
that's calculated by the mass of my body
times by acceleration due to gravity
times by the height to the top
[Music]
so now when I launched myself off the
top of this slide the force of gravity
will start accelerating me down turning
all that newly gained gravitational
potential energy into kinetic energy and
it's that that shoots me out the bottom
[Music]
so to all riders go down at the same
speed
well another has experiments where you
had dropped two balls once heavy and
ones light see them land at the same
time showing how gravity accelerates
them at the same rate
what does that happen with this too
[Music]
Chris Moneymaker how you doing eat my
ice cream what do you want
ah she white come on really look it's a
fine okay I just need to find someone
who's about double my weight to 40
perfect
I'm 120 so we're gonna race down these
slides do you think Chris is gonna be
slower faster or the same speed as week
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I saw much slower than Chris well we've
gotta think about all the forces
involved lonely is a gravity pulling us
down but there's also friction between
our bodies and the slide itself and on
top of that there's drag from air
resistance to think about as we build
speed the frictional and drag forces
build up and up until they reach an
equilibrium with the stallion force and
gravity the speed at which is
equilibrium happens is loners our
terminal velocity and Chris is greater
mass allows him to reach a greater
terminal velocity than me and so you go
sound faster as well as our body mass
there are many other complicated factors
that can affect our final speed on a
slide things like the shape of our
bodies the position in which we ride in
even the material of our swimsuits in
physics there's something known as the
coefficient of friction which is the
measurements of the ease with which two
objects can move against each other the
lower the coefficients the less friction
there is between these two objects and
that's very important if you're all
about achieving the fastest speed on a
slide
[Music]
the hunt we've learnt a bit of something
today about waterslides the only way you
can turn your own body into a vehicle to
get all the thrills of a roller coaster
I'll see you next time
[Music]